dein ganzes leben ist eine lüge bei
barcodes werden nicht die schwarzen
streifen gescannt sondern die weißen
zwischenräume was 22 fakten die dein
weltbild komplett zertrümmert
wusstest du dass frankreich und
großbritannien bereits zweimal überlegt
haben sich zu einem gemeinsamen land zu
fahren was überlegt euch einfach mal was
das für ein heftiges land wäre also das
hier ist ja frankreich also kennt ja
jeder und das ist ja das vereinte
königreich und die beiden zusammen dass
er einfach das heftigste land in europa
alles irgendwie so halb im wasser vor
allem auch in frankreich megageil das
klima auch untenrum und so dass er unten
rum
ja wir schauen mal weiter auf dem mount
everest liegen knapp 200 leichen von
denen einige seit jahrzehnten von
bergsteigern als orientierungs
was sie nutzen diese leichen als
orientierungspunkte auf dem weg zum
gipfel diese leiche hier wurde von
vorbei wandernden bergsteigern green
boots getauft weil niemand weiß um wen
es sich dabei wirklich handelt wie war
von 1996 bis 2014 wichtiger wegpunkt auf
der nordroute des berges dann verschwand
sie plötzlich auf bisher unerklärliche
weise bergsteigen ist sie haben meiner
meinung nach einfach komplett bescheuert
oder warum steigt man berg hoch
schild doch lieber im bett und coop
serien oder so gegen sie lustig der
papst früher türsteher in einem
nachtclub heftig aber war 1990 liegt
näher an der ermordung kennedys als am
heutigen tag ja okay das sind solche
standard fakten irgendwie weil der
einzelthemen paris so ein erfolg war kam
london auf die idee sich auch einen zu
bauen
und was das hier war dann der finale
entwurf der gebaut werden sollte teile
davon wurden aufgebaut allerdings ging
die firma flasche und das war das ende
des britischen eiffelturms heute steht
an dieser stelle übrigens das wembley
stadium
ok haben sowohl verpackt sein aber wie
dumm ist das denn bitte so denkt sich
london einfach in paris steht ein
eiffelturm oder wollen alle hin liegen
dem eiffelturm wir bauen uns auch ein
verdammt noch mal was andere leuchtet
irgendwie ein der cappuccino wurde nach
dem aussehen der kapuziner mönche bin
[Musik]
das fällt mir jetzt erst auf total
gruselig es gab eine rede für den fall
dass die erste mondlandung in einer
katastrophe endet hier ist sogar die
rede bis zum mittelalter liefen die
menschen so
ja und beschaffung des menschen gab es
auch noch keine menschen das ist genauso
ein toller fax die länder vorwort von
russland ist 007 das wusste ich schon
kim jong un ist jünger als harry potter
okay das musste jetzt wirklich nicht ich
wusste dass kim jong-un irgendwie so
zwischen 30 und 40 es ist oder so aber
wir machen direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten fakt einen moment ist eine
altenglische zeiteinheit und dauert
neunzig sekunden
das heißt wenn man jemandem gesagt
moment mal hat man 90 sekunden zeit
gut etwas düster und zum nachdenken
jedes jahr erlebst du unwissentlich den
jahrestag seines todes
[Musik]
wow
facebook ist nur deshalb weil mark
zuckerberg eine rot grün schwäche hat
rechts wenn anne frank und bud spencer
wurden im selben jahr geboren ja wow
und jetzt gehen sie hin kinderfoto und
erwachsenen alten foto um trotz
gehörlosigkeit zu komponieren übertrug
beethoven die vibrationen seines
klaviers mit einer stange an seinen key
fakten doch was ich wäre froh wenn ich
überhaupt klavier spielen könnte der
schiefe turm von pisa ist innen hohl
mein kopf auch der vibrator wurde nur
erfunden weil es doktoren zu anstrengend
wurde frauen zum orgasmus und wenn
einfach sonnen bild hier drunter der
älteste deine mutter witz ist 3500 jahre
alt und wurde auf einer steintafel im
irak gefunden of your mother ist
verstehe ich jetzt nicht weil ich bin in
englisch du bist nur eine stunde
autofahrt vom weltraum entfernt wenn du
gerade nach oben fahren könntest
das stimmt wenn man in einem flugzeug
ist und irgendwo hinfliegen ist man ja
auch meistens so irgendwie zwischen 10
kilometer reise höheren 30 kilometer
reise höher also krank 30 kilometer
fährt man ja irgendwie so einer halben
stunde mit dem auto durch die uv kamera
kannst du sehen wie du dich sonnencreme
so gut schützt
alter
das sieht ja es ist ja mal voll heftig
aus kann man sich uv kameras im internet
bestellt eigentlich voll die heftige
video idee mal bibi blocksberg richtiger
name ist eigentlich brigitte blut bevor
die serie wird brigitte blocksberg
reisen und babys beauty per das heißt
auch eigentlich brigittes beauty palace
sein ganzes leben ist eine lüge bei
barcodes werden nicht die schwarzen
streifen gescannt sondern die weißen
zwischenräume was an der stelle mich das
heutige videos allerdings auch beenden
meine damen und herren ich habe einfach
diesen artikel hier entdeckte dachte mir
oh das zertrümmerte richtig mein gehirn
wenn euch das video hier gefallen hatte
nicht eventuell nochmal auf solche
komischen fakten reagieren soll die
einem das gehirn zertrümmern
dann lass mal einen fetten leichter
freunde bei 50.000 leicht wenn ich das
dann demnächst mal wieder machen also
wenn es euch gefallen hat 50.000 gleich
welchen faktor wusstet ihr eventuell
schon was musst du dir beispielsweise
noch nicht schreibt sie gerne unten
kommentare und jetzt